hi I'm Stephen and I recently made a
video where I train with a kpop star
from one week in that video and actual
kpop star amber Lou sent me advice from
Korea and today I finally get to meet my
sensei we're gonna hang out we're gonna
eat some good food and see what a day in
a life of a kpop star really is let's go
welcome to BuzzFeed thank you so what
are you doing la right now I can see you
ou can see you topless that's it
yes I'm actually here for kakeland
viglione every year artists come from
creative to perform all around the world
like France Dubai New York you're in
France I wasn't friends you're gonna
liable yeah
international baby mmm on the side uh
I'm shooting a show well Gretchen Lucas
you have your own show my own show
that's dedicated to youth I'm fabulous
of course I actually asked my Twitter
followers like what do they want to ask
Keith offsets are you getting enough
rest because I'm so passionate I love
what I do
I don't think about sleep I don't think
about eating my team they tell me ever
eat like okay
what are your favourite food was a bit
your favorite food now we just get
jack-in-the-box tacos I really like
check the box done could do a - $4
Mountain Dew or doll you're okay Bob
sahar it's a great deal get 20 tacos you
know get a bag full of taco sauce let's
do it though get outta here oh it's so
like apart from my kpop life uh-huh I
used to work at my friends taco shop
what when I should can't cook so I can't
fried egg properly so I wouldn't like
every day to to just work to work Wow
make tacos cuz I really missed out on
living a normal life
yeah you're elevated in a society yeah I
try to surround myself in a environment
where I don't have those privileges yeah
everything that I
is it's a blessing you know I sing and
dance for a living
there's so much more to this life than
just my world yeah so can't believe I'm
a jack-in-the-box right now I get like
two daughters can we get like 20 monster
tacos please we went all out
go big or go home you know any crazy
stories I don't have those crazy fans
that people talk about they called
tossing pin fans things like your
private life
oh I don't consider hunting fans fans
because they're stalking you I have a
lot of other celebrities who have
saucing fans yeah I do not know how they
function as a fan I want the best for
whoever I like right safe I come I have
a dating scandal or whatever with
somebody and they hate on my boy or what
I mean don't hate on me huh I check the
private life hmm
you have good fans my fans with us I'm
so proud of you I want to meet a friend
of mine okay my name is Jen okay may say
she is the amber of buzz woo and most
importantly she's a tomboy so sexy come
on that's my best friend here at
BuzzFeed we just wanted to talk to you
but first we have a present for you
Hot Cheetos do you like hot cheeto I
love watching I eat hot cheetos every
morning I'm very happy right now
I gave you all these snacks because I
want to talk about like about you or
something I don't want to hear about the
kpop you're famous whatever like you
know it's cool you guys are beautiful
women alright thank you you guys also
don't dress as like what people
traditionally think as female like this
roughly hmm can you tell me a little bit
about that I have a big phobia of public
bathroom I've been harassed a lot like
this is like verbally harassed don't be
like oh this is the girls bathroom like
oh I am a girl you could just leave you
out that that's fine you look like a
girl like how dare you come in the
bathroom and then I don't believe you oh
my god I don't blame people for being
surprised I just don't know what to do
when it when they go
overreacts do you want me to show you I
don't know what else to do like just
because I dress a certain way they think
Oh amber wants to become a boy I just
like comfortable clothing I like sports
and I just happen to have short hair
everybody is sort of held to certain
gender expectations and I think if you
deviate outside of that people don't
know how to respond yeah leaving for
guys like be a man that's what some very
pressuring we should respect a person
for their individual this rather than
okay just because you're this yours yeah
just be yourself just be myself no yo
what are you playing oh can we go
do you like Pokemon when you're younger
yes I have all the cards oh my gosh
I played let's go quick quick quick
quick transpire if you think you're that
much of a Pokemon fan girl we're gonna
play a spelling bee
I'll talk come on execute oh my god Ichi
GE wrong let's err doctor hell they are
nope hey why no kangaskhan oh my gosh
okay
eh in China hey hey hey it whoa dang
thing is come on huh
over here at some random skate park yes
Amber's gonna skate yeah cuz I've never
done this before
you actually look like a pretty not like
a normal life ya do enjoy a lot of the
things that people do there's so much
cool stuff in the world I just want to
experience as much as I can before
skateboarding is all about overcoming
your fears Oh
whether it's skating eating tacos
scoring on stage like life is also
literally after this you're about to get
on stage yeah what does it feel like to
perform in front of hundreds of
thousands of people it's still really
exciting I can't really fathom at the
moment you know you're going from
getting ready news interviews fan greets
and then you go to do the show it just
feels like a euphoric like you see the
fans and they're all smiling they're
singing with you they allow you the
opportunity to do what you do even if
you meet just one fan each experience is
extremely humbling I've been doing this
for seven eight years now it's awesome
it's like how do I respond to all this
someone like me in my position you can
definitely get big-headed really easily
and forget a lot of things to be
thankful for it every moment is precious
there's no time to hate or no judge
people it's just like you know you're
cool let's do something cool with every
fans dream right there to hear that
they're cool from the favorite k-pop
oh my god you were so good yeah you look
what's up ah you like that ah I still
have a busy schedule now I'm gonna fill
so oh like okay well sorry yeah good
later yes before me your hometown
yeah they were clean welcome